hello and welcome to this video this is
me playing black against mr. serious
William Paschal he's a very it's got a
very low rating here for his standard
usually somewhat higher anyway we got a
Queens gambit declined and let's see at
article were maybe this is one of those
lines that I only superficially studied
because when I decided to to play the
Queens gambit declined some time i
looked at the last covariation mostly
which is well here is solid but also
somewhat somewhat boring so I am only
back then thawed okay you know if I have
time later stage I can also add the
terekhova well I never got around to
studied in detail so I'm just going to
play it yeah by ear so the same so a
five is a move that I would be
interested in here well maybe be 5c 5d
takes 95 it shouldn't be so bad okay and
so I didn't expect him to take but
socially possible so yeah again c5 here
maybe or is this weakening too much it
we can see be five square quite a bit
takes Knight eggs I mean this is going
to win day for pong if you chicks which
is not clear that it is so great but
anyway yeah probably it's good enough
hmm so it's giving giving the palm okay
i can after Queen moves i can take c3
and take a form I mean it's really not a
clear porn what probably has some kind
of compensation but anything better
maybe it hurts a little bit to do this
from a strategic point of view but it is
a good as a pawn so let's take it and
the bishop was very nice and the night
was unstable on c3 ebit a porn is a porn
still and I don't see him getting it
back too soon maybe the beep on you can
get back oopsy eight I wonder when's he
going why is he allowing in 93 more to
come it's surprising
hmm I don't know 93 looks somewhat
annoying at least 93 where's he going to
d2 probably okay I cannot taking only
two it's not really that great but okay
I have to go here anyway I guess Bishop
d3 no I got g6 girag t2 is happening I
can go d 4 by the way this is something
that I only now only now saw that's
rather rather good resource to have
didn't really see him at first at the
rookie on the fifth rank is and relevant
here for this here could take on the
Queen can you move the Queen to
something good I don't think so now all
of a sudden my bishop gets alive that
was my fear when I was taking on c3 and
go for that 94 business and so on that
my bishop won't be seven would be a very
bad piece but well they didn't happen
Group D for I thought queen d 4 but of
course he can take one see 80 on 85 so
roop d for this 92 Luke see one probably
something with the back rank
yeah it's probably going to work but
let's see first what she does maybe it's
a waste of time to think about it too
much yeah it proved to be the case here
i can go Bishop a six if anything else
fails and win some material i guess i
guess i'll do that wins the exchange
check they cannot take with the rook
even which is useful doubling on the
second rank maybe Luke c2 and let this
make quite some sense attacking that
night okay rook d2 is kind of
embarrassing so i have to go here my
intention is root 2 a 2 double on the
second yeah but it's not going to cover
f2 now
so it still cannot really move as rook
b3 how do i get b 3 n 9 24 is still a
pretty good piece of course and maybe
just maybe just be 3m I'm threatening
rogue f 2 a.m. and then promote TX takes
everything and then it takes me three
actually
takes everything he takes on b3 but then
I have to win with the exchange up the
suena okay it should win I mean the
exchange in itself is good but it's also
weak 493 so yeah I'm going to keep pawns
that's good not trade so much so that I
have something that I can attack
especially h4 looks like a good good
target ig2 was a good move but ok this
is not know Betty hi morning
now we cannot move this night yeah King
c-4 would be nice it's not going to work
okay so let's see maybe I can improve
somehow this maybe just here
I'm not really happy with how I played
this this feels like it could have could
have been done with more precision
really and it was really bad bad clean
slate check check check check check
check check check check white forfeits
on time good god I got quick at the end
all of the Sun yeah bear technical
player I should have won much much
clearer with the exchange of so let's
have a look there well this is a
somewhat standard position for this
opening this kind of position I'm not
really sure about the details I was
surprised that he took on a five I know
they do it sometimes but I was more
thinking of b5 even though after c5 it
looks like a decent position for me I
really don't know is is that is that the
right reaction to take he takes this as
I had kind of normal it what definitely
I think is a mistake is that he captured
here on c5 I guess he didn't he didn't
really
see that I got the the porn um
immediately something like this is what
I expected actually that she puts this
Bishop here now it gets interesting I
wasn't sure what I would do there c4 hmm
don't know it makes this pawn structure
somewhat somewhat rigid and this a form
as a possible possible issue takes 90 x
yeah Tim it's really just a pawn but I
thought he really gave me yeah he helped
me a lot by giving me this for free and
now stepping to f5 yeah and this one
yeah and this is essentially winning
it's really really not apparent what
what good reply still has and this is
really not doing much so I could have I
could have one here much quicker with
this as i saw i saw this move just
briefly but i couldn't really didn't see
that one it's very cute trapping the
Queen and so then it's much much easier
than to check to win okay well this is
easy to win but it wasn't it wasn't
necessary at all yeah maybe maybe hear
something else makes it easier okay it
was I can just do this and he cannot
defend both phones so that is easy
enough yes i said i played this very
sloppy needs technical part of the game
this is also should win maybe maybe
getting the route to g4 wasn't a good
idea after all no cable engine is on
minus five so if I'm probably still
winning very comfortably but yeah
so this was wrong Butchie one wins and
he cannot stop the pawn yeah by now has
14 seconds and check yeah here I'm
winning again yeah it was a bit bit
sloppy he played but was ok yeah I
wonder maybe it's really that he has to
go Bishop b5 Yemen this is probably the
critical moment down after capturing on
c5 my position quickly got quite much
better here this is some this is
probably equal but not a boring kind of
equal so interesting play going on ok
thanks for watching